soit ce qui est ici merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france et images
évidemment tout le monde s'en souvient
nous ont choqués créer de l'émoi dans
l'opinion dans quel état d'esprit
s'ouvre ce procès c'est un procès pour
moi qui est celui d'abord qui n'est pas
celui de vrais gilet jaune
je voudrais dire que les personnes qui
ont commises ces actes absolument
révoltant de voir voilà des objets du
patrimoine être attaqué à l'époque les
vrais coupables n'ont jamais été arrêtés
et je pense même qu'ils sont protégés il
ya eu à l'époque beaucoup de témoignages
de personnes disant que des hommes en
noir ayant revêtu un gilet jaune ont été
laissées en les a laissé s'introduire
sur place et je trouve très étrange
qu'on n'ait jamais arrêter les vrais
coupables
alors aujourd'hui où il ya des traces
adn ou il ya des caméras de surveillance
où il y avait quand même des moyens de
retrouver ces personnes je pense que
réellement j'apporte mon soutien à ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui dans ce procès
parce que pour moi ce sont des boucs
émissaires et les vrais gilet jaune sont
des gens qui étaient pacifiques qui
effectivement se sont retrouvés dans
cette nasse géante orchestrée par le
pouvoir et où des gens ultra radicaliser
qui ne sont pas des gilet jaune mais qui
ont enfilé un gilet jaune opportunément
sont venues pour saccager pour emmener
la masse vers la violence et pour
discréditer totalement le mouvement
donc je suis assez accablé de voir
partout dans la presse
c'est cet amalgame fait systématiquement
alors qu'on le sait aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs en janvier 2019
quatre personnes avaient déjà été
arrêtées et condamnées et c'était des
personnes issus des mouvances ultra
droite du gud notamment une mouvance qui
revendique d'appeler à tuer le bourgeois
est également on a vu autour de l'arc de
triomphe d'aider les dégradations
montrait que c'était des groupes
également de l'ultra gauche
donc c'est cette alliance d'une toute
petite minorité qui a été largement
laissé
faire à l'époque par les forces de
l'ordre et par le pouvoir qui ont
encouragé ça pour permettre de
discréditer tout un mouvement et je
trouve ça encore vraiment désolant
qu'aujourd'hui médiatiquement tout le
monde parle du procès deux gilet jaune
qui ont saccagé l'arc de triomphe
c'est ça la cie si je résume c'est une
énorme manipulation
oh oui c'est ce que j'allais dire sophie
tissier si je résume votre propos il ya
une forme de manipulation les dix
personnes qui sont sur le banc des
prévenus aujourd'hui ne sont pas les
réels coupable il y aurait eu une forme
de laisser faire c'est ça qu'on comprend
bien sûr c'est un lynchage
on est en train de lâcher des coupables
idéals n'est pas vide et au pardon pour
simplement montrer l'exemple et pour
discréditer encore une fois les gilet
jaune et pour dire regardez c'était des
personnes violentes s'étaient des
personnes on voit sur les images ce qui
jette principalement des projectiles
sont des personnes tout en noir
d'ailleurs et c'est ce qu'on appelle le
black block c'est une alliance ultra à
la fois extrême droite et extrême gauche
et qui est je tiens à le dénoncer
soutenu par les réseaux sociaux facebook
twitter
moi mon compte personnel moi qui suis
pacifique est censuré je tiens
aujourd'hui en direct a dénoncé le
pouvoir qui volontairement censure les
personnes pacifiques qui cherche à
organiser les luttes les réelles
opposant militants pacifiques gilet
jaune sont censurés et toutes les
mouvances ultra et violentes sont
boostées par les réseaux sociaux avec la
complicité de l'état de la police des rg
j'en sais rien dans tous les cas du
pouvoir il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
moi je suis fichée s alors que je suis
pacifique que je n'ai commis aucune
dégradation jamais j'ai toujours été
légaliste j'ai toujours prôné
d'organiser les manifestations
correctement pour justement éviter
empêcher l'infiltration de groupuscules
ultra et de se voir ici kg les
mobilisations des accusations on les
remet pas en cause ici et votre compte a
été fermé à quelle occasion
précisément voilà aujourd'hui par
exemple on m'a censuré c'est à dire je
suis shadowbane et je subis du shadow
banking
c'est un moyen qu'ont mis en place les
réseaux sociaux vous pouvez chercher sur
internet c'est on cache les les postes
des personnes qui sont shadowbane et mon
compte semble actif mais les personnes
ne reçoivent jamais de notification les
toutes les personnes qui suivent et les
algorithmes limite complètement la
portée de toutes les publications que je
fais moi mais qui est également les
personnes de mon groupe et les personnes
des de nos réseaux sociaux avec force
jaune donc ils ferment officiers
finalisation de la violence elle est
réelle en tout cas c'est votre opinion
vous exprimer sur rt france ce soir
clairement ça a porté un coup dur au
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune ce genre
d'imagés d'ailleurs les d'autres scènes
de violence qui en qui on sait
évidemment la violence la violence de
ces images est terrible et on déplore il
faut d inacceptable qu'il ait des gens
qui est profané l'arc de triomphe qui
est cassé qui ait commis des
dégradations ne peut pas laisser passer
on ne peut jamais justifier la violence
il faut savoir que ces groupuscules là
ils sont très minoritaires
le guide ou les groupes ultras extrême
gauche de black blocks sont quelques
centaines de personnes
et d'ailleurs ils sont parfois renforcée
par des militants ultra venus
d'allemagne de belgique ou d'italie ou
d'autres pays parce que c'est une
mouvance radicaliser qui est d'ailleurs
on peut dire promotionner quelque part
par aussi les médias et il y à toute
cette mouvance et cette fausse
stratégique régulièrement diffusés dans
les mouvements sociaux de dire il faut
faire les choses clandestinement
il faut être tous masqués aujourd'hui
c'est avec la crise covin à l'époque du
mouvement black blocks
il faut toujours être dans la dent dans
l'illégalité
il faut s'opposer à l'état de façon
ferme il faut être radicaux sinon on est
des vendus on est des collabos moi vous
savez je lutte depuis des années et de
fait d'être pacifiques et de revendiquer
le pacifisme j'ai reçu énormément
d'attaqués y compris de du camp
politique d'extrême gauche y compris par
exemple du
de la banda rechange je le cite voilà
monsieur rufin qui par exemple défendez
les groupes de black blocks à
l'assemblée nationale et cerveau non
disponibles peuple révolté y dénonçait
que soi-disant ces groupes étaient
censurés ce qui est faux ils sont en
réalité boosté par les réseaux sociaux
et d'ailleurs vous pouvez voir le nombre
de followers de cépages et la réalité
c'est qu'il ya une totale
instrumentalisation des groupuscules
violents qui vont infiltrer les
mouvements sociaux
pour lise pour les radicaliser afin de
discréditer et afin de faire monter
toujours cette violence parce que le
pouvoir en fait se sert de nos émotions
il se sert de la peur aujourd'hui avec
le co vite pour nous contrôler il se
sert également de nos colères et la
colère des gens elle est
instrumentalisée ci et pour la mener
vers une haine une haine contre la
police une haine évidemment des
bourgeois de l'oligarchie etc et faire
monter les tensions pour que les
mouvements s'autodétruisent parce que
plus les manifestants vont être dans une
radicalité plus ça renforce en réalité
l'état puisque ça justifie la montée de
la répression ça justifie des lois
violente et aux yeux de la population
qui regardent comme aujourd'hui ces
images de violence ils se disent oh là
là mais c'est scandaleux il faut les
contenir il faut des lois répressives il
faut une police plus forte pour les
empêcher etc
mais c'est vraiment une totale
manipulation de az et j'en suis témoin
parce que je la vis et je vous dis moi
qui suis pacifique je suis censuré je
suis empêché d'agir
personne ne relaient la parole de notre
groupe et je suis fichée s et je aimé
mes comptes sont censurés et shadowbane
est aujourd'hui clairement c'est
l'impunité sont sophie tissier justement
sur ces médias sociaux aujourd'hui vous
avez demandé des comptes vous avez eu
des des réponses après ce que vous
estimez jamais vraiment pas une censure
c'est ça c'est là c'est ça qui est
terrible
je n'arrête pas de contester les
décisions de facebook de twitter et on
n'a aucun moyen de recours
je ne fais je n'arrête pas d'envoyer des
mails de co2 de protestation en disant
c'est pas normal vous me couper mes
comptes pourquoi mais mes publications
de sont plus visibles je vois bien les
progressions des publications elle
n'avance jamais
jamais diffusé parfois j'ai des des
procédés auxquels je n'arrive pas
j'arrive par partager j'arrive pas a
commenté j'arrive tout un tas de choses
qui me sont enlevés et c'est la réalité
et on n'a aucun retour aucun moyen de
recours puisque twitter et facebook
étend aux états unis il faudrait les
attaques et aux états unis avec des
moyens énormes au niveau juridique que
je n'ai pas et pour l'instant je n'ai
aucun autre moyen que de dénoncer
publiquement et que de les accuser
j'accuse facebook djakus twitter de
fomenter la violence et de est de faire
en sorte que ça serve le pouvoir pour
discréditer les gens qui comme moi et
c'est de de militer pacifiquement et je
dis aux jeunes il faut absolument que
vous ne tombiez pas dans le piège de la
violence qui est vraiment le meilleur
moyen de renforcer l'état vous êtes
persuadé d'être dans une opposition vrai
et dans une désobéissance
alors que c'est le pire moyen pour
renforcer en réalité le pouvoir de la
police que d'être que d'être dans une
confrontation et de revendiquer cette
confrontation et c'est ce qui a
malheureusement détruit les gilet jaune
aujourd'hui quel est votre moyen de vous
vous exprimez si vous n'avez pu les les
réseaux sociaux on a très peu de moyens
merci de me donner la parole samedi
dernier nous avons organisé une
manifestation avec force jaune et avec
beaucoup d'autres groupes d'ailleurs
collectif contre la dictature sanitaire
c'était place de la fontaine des
innocents à châtelet-les-halles on était
quelques centaines de personnes
aucun relais média personne n'a parlé de
cette manifestation on en organise une
de nouveau samedi prochain d'ailleurs
j'invite toutes les personnes qui sont
révoltés contre la gestion de la crise
sanitaire et qui dénonce aussi la
dictature sanitaires à venir samedi à la
manifestation à 14h à
châtelet-les-halles c'est une
manifestation déclarée autorisé où il
n'y a aucune violence policière
parce que la police fait très bien le
distinguo les policiers du terrain
savent très bien que notre groupe n'est
pas du tout dans un objectif de violence
et de et de casse et d'agressivité donc
on a tout à fait l'autorisation est
d'ailleurs nous avions été avec force
jeune j'avais été moi même plaidé
7 novembre dernier au tribunal
administratif pour protéger le droit de
manifester puisque le préfet de police
sous prétexte des mesures sanitaires à
faire respecter interdisait les
manifestations et empêcher les
déclarants comme notre groupe de pouvoir
manifester à l'époque au parvis des
droits de l'homme et je suis allé au
tribunal administratif de paris plaider
la cause de la liberté de manifester et
défendre par le droit notre liberté et
nous avions gagné on avait levé fait
lever trois arrêtés préfectoraux
d'ailleurs rt vous nous aviez vous aviez
informer les téléspectateurs de de cette
action juridique et grâce à cette action
aujourd'hui on continue d'avoir le droit
de manifester en france donc on le fait
samedi et les suivants on va être tous
les samedis place de la fontaine des
innocents avec un maximum de collectif
il ya des réseaux comme le réseau rsa
les collectifs de parents contre le mas
pour les enfants mais également réaction
19 enfants ces libertés plein de
collectif
ami entends-tu qui sont des artistes qui
demande l'ouverture des théâtres
il faut aujourd'hui qu'on défende notre
liberté de manifester parce que c'est
fondamental si on veut défendre nos
droits et nos libertés il faut pouvoir
manifester et manifester pacifiquement
pour pas avoir évidemment ni la police à
doni la gendarmerie à dos et pour pas
dégrader l'image des mouvements pour
pâques à la télévision on focalise tous
sur les violences
les violences policières la montre
l'escaladé de la violence et des
tensions qui à la fois font peur à ceux
qui regardent les gens n'ont plus envie
de venir
comme on a peur quand on voit de ces
images terrifiantes de deux voitures
brûlées de violence les gens se disent
mais surtout faut pas leur manifestation
et ils craignent d'être réprimée donc
nous on a réussi avec notre groupe à
mettre en place ce processus de
déclaration de manif collective
on revendique le pacifisme et ça
fonctionne et on est en train de monter
une grande coordination
stop à la dictature sanitaires stop aux
masques pour les enfants parce que c'est
odieux ce qu'ont fait subir vos
anciennes
une dernière question je suis notamment
toutes les mesures vous y croyez à cette
suite c'est ma dernière question est
très rapidement si vous pouvez vous y
croyez à cette suite du mouvement fut
justement d
gilet jaune aujourd'hui après la crise
peut-être du coc vide écoutez les gilet
jaune ça a été un mouvement tellement
historiques mondial ça a été vu ça a été
repris dans le monde entier
bien sûr qu'il ya eu cette perte de
vitesse je pense que
l'instrumentalisation du coc vidé pour
énormément dans la l'amenuisement du
mouvement mais croyez moi il ya encore
beaucoup de gens en gilet jaune qui sont
qui soutiennent les jets les jeunes dans
leur coeur et qui ont compris aussi les
manipulations qu'il y a eu pour empêcher
ce mouvement de s'organiser de grandir
de progresser dans la bonne direction et
nous en tous les cas moi c'est à ça que
j'offre de tout mon coeur j'ai vraiment
envie que tous les gens qui ont soutenu
le mouvement à un moment tous les gens
qui ont sorti chez les jeunes reviennent
suis fort ce jeu nous montrent des
groupes force jaune partout en france
parce que nous avons une charte
nous avons une charte de valeurs et qui
est fidèle à l'origine du mouvement a
partisans sans syndicats un mouvement
citoyen avec que des gens qui
revendiquent leurs droits leur liberté
leurs droits fondamentaux de pouvoir
vivre dignement de la justice sociale
après tout les évidemment toutes les
revendications mais aujourd'hui surtout
de défendre la liberté nos libertés
fondamentales qui sont en train d'être
détruite par l'instrumentaliser la crise
la suivante alisation de la crise merci
beaucoup merci de m'avoir donné la
parole aux lakers inertie témoignages et
merci pour votre témoignage sophie
tissier coordinatrice de l'association
force jaune